er hat mir ganz viele fragen gestellt
deswegen nehme ich euch heute einfach
mal mit durch den tag und versuche dabei
so viele von euren fragen zu beantworten
wie ich irgendwie schaffe welche gemüse
würdest du empfehlen in einem garten
anzupflanzen
zu dem man nur circa alle zwei wochen
hinfahren kann
das ist ja so ein bisschen wie bei
unserem acker ne wir haben ja diesen
garten hier bin ich eigentlich jede
woche unterwegs und ich bin auch jeden
tag hier weil auch die hühner hier sind
aber wir haben auch einen acker der ist
nochmal größer
die nutzen wir gar nicht mehr so
intensiv weil sie eigentlich ziemlich
viel anbaufläche auch hier haben aber da
lasse ich alle pflanzen die nicht so
viel aufmerksamkeit brauchen und von
denen wir auch richtig viel masse
brauchen also zb kartoffeln sind ja in
der selbstversorgung einfach super super
wichtig dann gibt es noch ein paar
andere kandidaten einmal sind dann noch
karotten und pastinaken und zwiebeln in
einer mischkultur auch der meiste
knoblauch wächst hier hier habe ich zwar
auch welchen aber den großen acker voll
knoblauch wo dann richtig körbeweise
ernte anfällt der wächst nicht hier im
küchengarten der kirchengarten dass er
für die laufende ernte jetzt zum
beispiel endlich ganz viele ärzten bis
mittag essen wir machen dann gucken doch
nicht mal gucken wie kartoffelbrei mit
ärztenetzen das beste gemüse dass es
gibt finde ich wechsele kämpfen so süß
im gepäck dann wächst noch rote beete
auf dem acker und normalerweise auch
eine mischkultur aus meisten stammkunden
und kürbis und das sind die kandidaten
die wir auf dem acker anbauen und die
sie einmal pflanzen oder serien im
frühling dann kommen wir vielleicht ein
zweimal noch im sommer vorbei um zu
düngen und mache zu schauen wie alles so
läuft werde ich den rasen zu mähen und
dann gehen wir nur noch zu ernten
das heißt ich bin in einem im sommer
vielleicht viermal wirklich da und
trotzdem funktioniert das wunderbar mit
diesem kandidaten die nächste frage ist
wie man eine fruchtfolge einhalten kann
wenn man zb nur ein oder zwei bieter hat
weil ich ja gesagt habe dass jedes
gemüse je nach pflanzenfamilie nur alle
drei jahre
oder alle sechs jahre auf ein und
demselben bild wachsen sollte damit man
zum beispiel krankheiten und schädlinge
aus hungert und damit die nährstoffe
auch besser genutzt werden körper dann
aber nur ein oder zwei beete hat dann
ist das natürlich gar nicht so einfach
das einzuhaltende man will ja nicht nur
jedes sechste jahr kohl in seinem garten
anbauen sondern eigentlich jedes jahr
ein bisschen cool wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel nur ein beet hat dann kann man
sich ganz gut helfen indem man dieses
bild dann einfach in sechs teile
einteilt einfach im kopf
da wächst parzellen draus macht und
diese sechs parzellen die betrachtet man
dann wie sechs einzelne beete in der
fruchtfolge und rotiert die
untereinander durch und dann kann man
auch in einem oder zwei beten mit tolle
fruchtfolge einhalten da muss man
einfach so ein bisschen so einen
gedanken switch machen und dann ist das
gar kein problem ich hoffe das ist
verständlich und ihr könnt euch
vorstellen was ich meine
[Musik]
das sind jetzt die letzten lager finde
ich noch in der täter hatte
ich war ein bisschen inkonsequent mit
dem zu machen deswegen hier haben die
ein bisschen licht abbekommen und sind
ausgetrieben aber die sind immer noch
richtig viel spaß ich bin total
begeistert von der miete und wir haben
gleichzeitig auch schon die ersten drei
von kartoffeln im weg stehen ich will
erst mal die alten auf essen bevor ich
die neuen und breche sozusagen
und ja das ist aber etwas ruhig nicht
mega treue das ist ganz besonderes
gefühl wenn man die ersten kartoffeln
ausgräbt und auch nicht so an weiß was
ein unter der erde erwartet aber ein
bisschen geduld muss ich noch haben wir
müssen erst mal weg ein befreiter
kartoffelbrei
[Musik]
und eine frage die ganz viele von euch
ein bedauern hoch bewertet haben war
habe ich mal was zum balkon gärtnern
machen kann kann ich super gerne also
ich habe tatsächlich angefangen auf den
balkon zu gärten und mit 12 auf der
dachterrasse meinen eltern
da hatten wir noch gar keinen garten und
so habe ich mir angefangen das gärtnern
beizubringen das heißt ich kann da auch
eine ganze menge zu erzählen
vielleicht habe ich jetzt schon mal
super tipps und zwar was ich immer
wieder gemerkt habe war das ist super
wichtig ist dass die pflanzen große
töpfe haben so dass sie ihre wurzeln
schön ausbreiten können
dann muss man auf dem balkon auch
ziemlich viel gießen weil hier ist gar
nicht so viel zu tun eigentlich bei den
tomaten vielleicht ein paar blätter noch
unten raus nehmen das mache ich immer
gerne
aber zurück zum balkon große töpfe
regelmäßig gießen da muss ein bisschen
kreativ werden weil man ja meistens
nicht so viel platz hat aber alles
mögliche anbauen möchte und habe ich mir
auch sowie artikel sachen gebauten
erdbeer turm und so weiter da gibt es
auch richtig coole ideen zum beispiel
oft angeles das finde ich immer ganz
spannend sich da so ein paar gartenideen
abzustauben und töpfe sollte man auch
dringend mulchen das ist ganz wichtig
ich sag ja immer heute durch teure beese
das ist aber beim gärtnern im hochbeet
oder im topf auch noch umso wichtiger
weil die eben sehr viel schneller
austrocknen das heißt da immer alles
schön rund um die pflanzen tür mit
grasschnitt bedecken oder mit laub dann
ist es noch ganz wichtig dass das wasser
gut abfließen kann
das heißt ich habe immer im unten in die
töpfe ein bisschen griesheim gepackt
damit da keine staunässe entsteht und
natürlich immer töpfe verwenden wo das
wasser dann auch durch abfließen kann
mit untersetzern weil stellt euch mal
vor die pflanzen stehen nach dem gießen
dann immer noch in dieser matsche pampe
des zu denen überhaupt nicht gut sehen
dass das wasser abfließen sonst verraten
euch die wurzeln
[Musik]
ich finde das durchaus anderes an habe
ich war noch beim zahnarzt zwischendurch
und da konnte ich nicht mit meiner
jetzigen gestalt aufkreuzen außerdem ist
es so unfassbar hoffen dass es gar nicht
anders geht sind kleider anzuziehen sah
machen wir weiter mit der nächsten frage
nicht wundern wenn ich immer darunter
gucke weil ich da die fragen
aufgeschrieben habe mich würde
interessieren wie es mit euren hof
plänen aussieht gibt es da was neues
oder liegen die aktuell erst mal auf eis
wo wohnt ihr zurzeit könnt ihr den
garten weiter nutzen
okay das sind viele fragen ich habe euch
erzählt dass wir aus unserem alten
zuhause ausziehen mussten wir holen da
gekündigt video kann ich euch gerne da
oben verlinken
das war ein großer schock wir haben aber
eine neue wohnung gefunden
ohne garten können aber zum glück den
garten weiter nutzen bis wir ein haus
gefunden haben ich habe euch auch
erzählt mein größter traum überhaupt
überleben das ist ein bauernhof zu haben
und richtig viel platz für alle
möglichen tiere und bäume und beete und
so weiter die ich gerne hätte
es ist aber nicht so leicht etwas zu
finden weil wir sehr an die regionen
hier gebunden sind und so war es nicht
irgendwas tut werde ich natürlich
natürlich euch dann auch auf den weg mit
dem wie bist du eigentlich zum thema
selbstversorgung gekommen liegt ihr das
im blut also ist das in der familie
schon immer ein thema gewesen
doch hat es glaube ich mal etwas von
einer ur großmutter erzählt meine
familie meine eltern wie direkte familie
haben mit gemüse werden selbstversorgung
überhaupt nichts am hut ich bin
in der stadt aufgewachsen zweiten grünen
viertel und ich wollte mal raus zusammen
häuser bauen und das naturschutzgebiet
vergleichen die ecke so also in jetzt
nicht mitten in der city aber es war
irgendwie schon immer in die also sobald
ich zurückdenken kann wollte ich immer
eigene tiere haben und nicht nur zum
kuscheln sondern ich wollte meine eigene
mädchen melden und ich wollte meine
eigene gemüse an war oder das war
irgendwie schon immer da und vielleicht
konnte schon aus der familie ich habe ja
gesagt habe meine urgroßmutter mal ein
zelt
die hat einen riesigen garten und die
hat ganz arg dafür gebrannt und ich
versuche immer so zu erklären weil ich
das eine schöne vorstellung finde das
sehen wir das mit gegeben hat und ich
hätte sie wahnsinnig gerne in echt
kennen gelernt ja aber zum glück hat
meine eltern das super mitgemacht also
die haben mir als ich zwölf war eine
eine ziegenherde geschenkt also dass
welche eltern machen sowas schon wenn
man mitten in der stadt und da habe ich
überhaupt nicht mit gerechnet und es war
mein allergrößter wunsch ich liebe
ziegen schon immer und habe immer der
medizin der nachbarn gefüttert hat mich
um sie gekümmert und dann hat mein vater
gesagt komm wir gehen spazieren auf
einem geburtstag und dann sind wir durch
das naturschutzgebiet außen und dann
meinen sie ja kommt man das in so süße
ziel und ich habe mich natürlich schon
sofort entdeckt und fand es total
niedlich das waren drei relativ jungen
ziegen und dann hat er auf einmal gesagt
dass sie mir gehört und das war ein
unglaublicher moment
das werde ich nie vergessen
und das hat mich auch ganz schön geprägt
weil er weiter 12 das heißt da war noch
nicht in der pubertät oder so und dann
mit rechts sehen aber immer noch hin zu
gehen jeden tag den stall auszumisten
die fingernägel und jungs und party ist
eigentlich viel interessanter bahn hat
mir auf jeden fall total gut getan und
jetzt habe ich immer noch ziegen 14 15
jahre später und gar nicht ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht vorstellen diese wäre
ohne die zu sein auch wenn sie feucht
sind weil sie andere hacker machte wird
ständig über den zaun springen aber ich
lief sie einfach heißt entdecken und
dann die nachricht auf dem balkon
angefangen zu werden und an meinen
eltern schon noch bevor ich die zehn
hatte und dann später auch im richtigen
garten und so hat sich das dann alles
entwickelte sind dann auch die linie
dazu bekommen weil das war irgendwie
schon immer da und zwar mit schon immer
klar dass ich mein leben möchte das
leben
[Musik]
die nächste frage ist hat er auch mal in
den urlaub und was macht ihr dann mit
dem garten wir haben jedes jahr dieses
problem was die bewässerung betrifft und
ich war tatsächlich morgen früh in
urlaub ich bin gerade am packen und
tatsächlich ist das für milch
mittlerweile gar kein problem weil ich
eine sehr tolle ziegen täterin habe
hallo an kelly begriffe und deswegen
weiß auch wenn ich weg bin sind die
tiere auf jeden fall gut versorgt und im
garten habe ich eigentlich gar nicht so
viele probleme wenn ich weg bin weil ich
gehe ja sowieso nicht gehst als ich
diese meine gemüse immer nur solange sie
noch ganz klein sind wenn sie gerade
frisch bepflanzt sind oder frisch
ausgesetzt sind aber danach müssen die
selber klarkommen da haben wir so ein
paar unterschiedliche techniken mit
denen man wasser im boden speichern kann
da kann ich auch gerne das video da oben
zu verlinken der ist könnt ihr euch
gerne mal anschauen
das ist super praktisch wenn man einfach
flexibel sein will und nicht ständig
dann jemanden zum gießen irgendwie
organisieren
das einzige was ich regelmäßig gießen
sind meine hochbeete die halten das aber
auch ganz gut aus wenn ich mal zwei
wochen nicht da bin
aber das gewächshaus gieße ich eben
einmal in der woche und genau wenn ich
als länger als eine woche wegfahren
würde würde ich dann schauen dass
irgendwer das gewächshaus in der 2
liest man kann es ja nicht reinreden
dass das problem deswegen ist man darauf
gießen angewiesen aber draußen eben
eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht und das
ist richtig praktisch also video packe
ich auch gerne noch unterliegen die
richtung und ich nehme euch auch mit den
urlaub morgen über antworten gleich noch
mehr fragen
nicht weil wir interessieren wie es dazu
kam dass du nach zehn jahren aufgehört
hast vegan zu leben
ich hole - also ich war sehr lange
veganen und dann musste ich aus
gesundheitlichen gründen auf gluten
verzichten
es heißt ich konnte gar kein gluten
messen und dadurch habe ich dann so
stark abgenommen weil ich so wenig
sachen nur noch essen konnte und mir das
essen auch irgendwann gar keinen spaß
mehr gemacht hat und dann wenn ich
irgendwann im supermarkt gewesen und
habe an der fleischtheke gestand oder
bin halt vorbei gelaufen und ich möchte
da gar nix kaufen
aber dann habe ich auf einmal richtig
viel spucke im mund gehabt und hatte so
unglaublich heiß hunger auf fleisch und
das irgend ein paar monate dass ich
jedes mal wenn irgendwo vielleicht war
unglaubliche lust darauf bekommen habe
das war wie so ein zeichen von meinem
körper an habe ich ein blutbild machen
lassen eisenwerte waren okay aber
irgendwann habe ich dann gedacht ich
kann das jetzt nicht mehr länger
ignorieren und dann habe ich gedacht ich
muss irgendwie eine ethische hre
es gibt keine ethische art fleisch zu
essen meiner meinung nach aber eine
ethische möglichkeit finden um zumindest
ein ganz bisschen fleisch in meine
nahrung ist offen habe zu integrieren
und dann habe ich angefangen wird es zu
essen weil ich dachte die wild lebenden
tiere sind vielleicht die die noch das
glücklichste leben hatten und damit ich
von damen übergegangen zu hey ich hab ja
ziegen früher habe ich die auch selber
gegessen und wenn man schon fleisch ist
dann noch von kirin wo man von vorne bis
hinten weiß wo das fleisch herkommt und
wo man weiß man hat alles getan damit
dieses tier ein so glückliches leben
führen kann wie es einem irgendwie
möglich ist und dann ist es vielleicht
ein bisschen okay die böckchen die übrig
bleiben
sowieso schlecht verkaufen kann dann
selber zu essen und das mache ich auch
nur einen sehr kleinen umfang es ist
jetzt zweieinhalb jahre her dass ich
wieder angefangen habe fleisch zu essen
und in der zeit habe ich weniger als
zwei tiere gegessen also wir haben am
anfang dann zwei ziegen geschlachtet und
davon habe ich immer noch fleisch übrig
und ja das heißt es ist nicht viel aber
es hilft mir diesen reis hunger nicht
mehr zu haben und ist finde ich ja ich
habe immer noch damit auch das okay ist
oder nicht
aber es ist für mich eine bessere lösung
als einfach im laden zu gehen und sich
da das anonyme fleisch zu kaufen wenn
jemand überhaupt nicht weiß wo es
herkommt beziehungsweise eigentlich
schon erahnen kann dass es sich hier
nicht gut gegangen ist ist ein
schwieriges thema ich möchte da auch
niemanden angreifen der jetzt irgendwie
eine andere meinung hat ich habe mich
damit sehr viel auseinandergesetzt bin
aber auch noch nicht an dem punkt wo ich
sagen kann das ist jetzt meine für immer
gültige lösung und so legt es unbedingt
machen wieso macht mich jemand aus
seinem team den job sondern der fabi und
rede nicht ein dass barbie der machen
jetzt einen coolen neuen daten schafften
ich habe ja schon angekündigt dass ich
auch mal meinen eigenen shop machen
möchte und ich glaube dass ein paar
leute ein bisschen verwirrt und
mannschaft kommt auf jeden fall und
farbe weiß dass auch von anfang an sehr
klar kommuniziert
das finde ich auch so wichtig ist wie
gesagt wenn du online gießen bei einem
shop wollen wir wollen ja ich verbreite
ich hab so viel zu tun ich habe richtig
bock meine eigenen job zu machen und
auch eigene produkte zu entwickeln und
ich wirklich selber entwickelt habe das
wird auf jeden fall kommen weil ich habe
dann mega bock drauf aber im moment ist
das zeitlich einfach nicht drin
und das war jetzt eine super möglichkeit
um von diesen emission verlinkungen
wegzukommen und gleichzeitig zu
unterstützen damit du dir was eigenes
aufbauen kannst und es ist eine tolle
übergangslösung für mich und du willst
bis in anderthalb jahren wenn ich meinen
eigenen shop hoffentlich irgendwann
aufgebaut habe auf eigenen beinen stehen
und dann wird es nicht so schlimm sein
wenn ich dann mehr auf mich selber
verlinken und nicht mehr hab dich mal so
und so der plan
genauso ist wie gesagt auch ein riesen
gegen kommen wir wie es mit hilfe meiner
seite
vielen dank dafür und dann euch
natürlich auch ja mehr heute sind wir
online gegangen habe mir das video
ablehne und beachtet und mehr freut mich
dass das feedback bis jetzt sehr sehr
lieb von euch sehr positiv ausgefallen
ist da freue ich mich riesig darüber
oder freuen uns riesig darüber auf wie
recht viel entwickelt viel gearbeitet
aber gerne auch es macht spaß ich habe
kein problem damit bisschen gemacht
teilweise auf 34 uhr versetzen ohne dies
helfe und eure hilfe werde es überhaupt
nicht möglich gewesen also nochmal ganz
viel liebe geht raus vielen dank wieso
hast du kennst das liegt daran dass ich
ganz lange gar kein handy hatte
beziehungsweise ich hatte einst aber das
hat halt eigentlich die die christa
derzeit in der schublade verbracht und
ich hatte das mal so einmal in der woche
an
bis vor einem halben jahr ungefähr
und jetzt habe ich ein handy und habe
dass ich bin schon sehr gut erreicht
beim bund würde hat sich was getan ich
bin im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert an
aber ehrlich gesagt wie gesagt ich habe
so viel zu tun dass ich gerade nicht die
luft hätte noch ein
inhalt zu bespielen und wenn nicht
längst machen wir dann richtig sodass er
sagt noch cool wird und jeweils davon
habt aber wie gesagt da du ja schon du
hast deinen blog durst youtube winter
ist auch noch dann jetzt ticket kostet
gemacht aber das sind trotzdem schon mal
facebook schon drei oder vier große
kanäle die droge spielen muss ich würde
sagen generell qualität statt quantität
es kostet halt acht lassen dass es mehr
zeit am bildschirm und weniger zeit im
garten und weniger 13.000 sehr schöner
werden
wir haben ein porträt von nächste frage
wird es normal mit mir einen kaffee
trinken jahren einen vielleicht ich habe
das mit dem kaffeesatz noch nie so
richtig wie oft haben die frage schon
also es gab manchmal aber ich werde ich
die körper aktiv frank ich habe heute
morgen ein getrunken ich nix immer noch
nicht diesmal leichter ist ein leichter
aber ich drehe davon durch ich habe mich
auch in französisch abitur mit cola
gedopt die lehrer müssten mich daraufhin
hat sich super 25 positive untersuchen
und dann habt ihr alles gefasst sondern
sie hat es ja durchaus positive
auswirkungen
dann kommt mein buch raus das wird
wahrscheinlich nächstes vorher raus
kommen
ich bin jetzt ungefähr halb fertig mit
dem manuskript das rot schon eine ganze
weile weil eben immer viel zu tun ist
und er sollte auch eigentlich schon
draußen sein aber das kommt und es wird
wunderschön was der auch schon ein paar
fotos gesehen
stell dir mal vor in ihrem buch
abgedruckt von vorne befinden wenn du
warst so was im wirklich in den händen
halten kannst also auch solche fotos
haben ganz anderen mann hat einen ganz
anderen eindruck und finde ich es hat
eine ganz andere wirkung auf ein so es
wird kein reines gartenbuch sondern es
geht auch um haltung und brotbacken und
ziegenhaltung und das ist ein
selbstversorger rundumschlag und das
richtig richtig cool auch um cyber
machen geht ist also ein bisschen zeit
brauchen wir noch aber ich werde es
diesen sommer fertig schreiben und dann
kommt das nächste serie aus
[Musik]
aber schöner gedanke
hier kommt rein
[Musik]
ich hoffe ihr hattet spaß bei dem video
ich verlinke euch da trieben ein video
das euch interessieren könnte ansonsten
geht raus macht die welt ein bisschen
grüner springt in einem lee und wir
sehen uns nächsten samstag wieder um 10
uhr pärchen youtube